[Music]
hello and welcome to spectator TV I'm
James heel I'm joined today by The
Spectators ktie bulls and former labor
adviser John murnan now today K dama has
been reshuffling his top team on the
labor front bench Katie what are the
main takeaways from today so I think as
was broadly expected the five missions
so uh ultimately not as catch has the
five priorities but the five missions
for a labor government that k d has set
up the shadow cabinet members who have
briefs that correspond with that have
not been moved um so despite some
excited talk a few months ago of Ed
milleran could be in trouble um you know
is kiss Armor after axbridge even though
usas is a separate issue of course to
some of these Net Zero Energy goals
going to um you know change the brief
that em has that has not happened and
instead probably the the most you know
headline change is Angela Raina who has
uh gone from having multiple job titles
if you think back to 2021 where there
was a labor Reef that went very wrong
for K dor because he stripped an the Rea
of her chairman role and then all of a
sudden the whole thing was held up
because an sha and her team were not
happy with many of the other things that
were being suggested and eventually she
negotiated it so she had multiple briefs
and it was seen as a sign of her
strength and K st's weakness I think
today actually the reuer been pretty
seamless and you have a situation where
Angela Raina has changed roles but has
gone well for both sides so she is now H
taking on the role that Lisa nandy had
which is leveling up and housing
secretary and she also is no longer just
described as Deputy labor leader which
of course is a role that k d cannot take
away from her because it was picked by
labor members when he was picked as
labor leader she's also at Shadow Deputy
Prime Minister so it was just
confirmation um that she would would be
Deputy Prime Minister in a labor
government um it's something she's
spoken about public before saying you
know K starm is in trouble if he doesn't
give me that joking about it saying you
know she's his John Prescott um but it
does just show I think that they You
know despite talks of friction there's
an effort to say this person is staying
close they have a role in in in these
and therefore Lisa nandy demoted quite a
few demotions but I think another theme
um which uh John has picked up on is
actually the rise of the Blair rights
and actually there are quite a few
candidates such as promotion for Pat MC
in which Su just a right of the party is
in the ascendancy uh John you did
probably my favorite tweet of the day
pointing out that no less than five
spads uh special advises from Tony
Blair's era are now in the shadow
cabinet who are they and what do they
now represent in terms of their
promotions um I actually miscalculated
there's six of them because there's Ed
millerand um there's Pat mcfaden there's
Liz Kendall uh there's Hillary Ben um
there's Johnny Ashworth uh and here's my
sixth
one uh Peter Kyle Peter kle so we've got
um half a dozen new Labor uh Shadow cab
members and three actually um Shadow
cabinet members who were in the cabinet
uh with brown and Blair um so what
you've got is I for me you've got the
ultimate settling of the soft left and
uh the Blair rights and they're going to
run they're going to run the party and I
hope run the country and it's that part
of his experience part of his ideology
it was you know Liz Kendall was beaten
in the labor leadership election but she
framed the terms of the debate under
which K starmer has won back the labor
party when she said um in that debate
that that famous thing she said you know
country first party second she got
punished by the label party membership
for being so patriotic but she laid the
basis for the claim of progressive
patriotism and I think that's been
rewarded now her Talent on the on in the
ministerial team her T her work on
social care she's finally got the top in
Department work Adventures uh where she
and I both worked together for Harriet
Haron um uh back in uh the beginning of
the BL 9798 so I see experience coming
back I see the the wisdom of keeping uh
Ed millerand in the shadow cabinet a
really important uh figure to reach the
left of the part to reach to younger
voters to reach to Greener voters and
the importance of actually Andie rer
deciding yeah it is time for a real job
it's time for jobless about housing
about planning about Regional inequality
about the future plans for Devolution
how the uh how how we'll actually
devolve powers to Mayors how will
devolve powers to local government so
something big about what what what what
Angie's done because it shows her
confidence but it also shows Kier is in
charge this is Kier st's first cabinet
he's not had to worry about the balance
he's promoted Talent demoted people for
poor performance moved people out the um
out the shadow cabinet completely uh in
the case of Rosetta um and I think it is
the way it moves so quickly and so
slickly is a tribute to the hand behind
the scenes of sug gr first day as Chief
of Staff this is i that's first foral
working day I doubt it's the first day
she' been working with Kier um because
it's all gone really well and on the
other side the politics the wheels keep
falling off or the roofs keep falling in
I'm not sure what metaphor we should be
using well sticking to Labor ktie uh you
know John there mentioned about the
Blair era ministers cabinet ministers
one surprise picked from today was
Hillary Ben coming back a bit of a labor
veteran um seven years ago was sacked
after the E referendum by Jeremy Corbin
in the subsequent leadership dyma that
was quite an interesting role but
perhaps you know a sensible one as well
yeah and he's in the Northern Ireland
brief which of course is uh very
important when you think of the Windsor
framework but future relations
um K has always been quite clear I think
on that that you know I think alignment
and ultim having a pragmatic way to
avoid checks as what they would want to
do he likes to contrast himself as
different to the ideological brexit is
so rishy came up at The Winds of
framework he was saying you know you can
have the votes we'll help you get the
votes over if you have these people who
will not compromise um and even though
at the time wasn't clear there would be
a vote on it um they managed to use that
position I think Hillary Ben is is some
H is also quite good at compromise if
you think about uh during the brexit era
when there were multiple brex Wars was
he was one of those people almost in the
middle of the labor party in terms of
trying to come up with compromises on it
um so I think that's telling I think
another thing that's quite striking from
this reshuffle is as John says you know
Blair right soft left what about loyalty
to Kama because um if you think about
Jim McMahon he's someone who has
resigned citing uh some personal issues
coming back from an illness but someone
who was also I think heavily briefed as
someone who was you know seen as not
performing as someone in the leader's
office would like um in his environment
brief they really want to go on the
attack on sewage Steve Reid has been put
in there in his place now Steve Reed is
close to Morgan mcweeny who's a key
strategist for K starma but also I think
Steve Reed we've seen from the labor
attack ads in the spring was someone who
was quite happy to get his hands dirty
and come out and say Le's adverts are
completely fine you know people you know
and make that argument and therefore I
think in a brief where they really want
to go on their attack on the Tories you
can see that appointment then also you
land look at Nick Thomas Simmons who has
been
demoted ultimately someone who has been
pretty loyal to kiss starma when you
divide up the shadow cabinet um but yet
has really had quite a full from Grace
if you think about when K dama first
made up his shadow cabinet this person
was Shadow Home Secretary and as slowly
seeing the roles reduced furly now it's
a cabinet office role uh Shadow role and
and therefore it feels as though loyalty
alone and having bad kissed armor is not
enough to keep you a plush job I think
there is you know depending on who you
speak to her and caveats and denials
coming I'm sure but there are some who
say you know oh he spends too much
writing a book um not enough time on the
role and that that put some nose out
joint previously um of course a book
isn't a really a blocker to everything
because word streeting has a Booker and
it's being lots of promotion and is
still sitting pretty of course in Shadow
Health yeah John ktie makes a great
point there talking about how differing
The Fortunes are in K's First Shadow
cabinet and a lot of the people who are
now getting top jobs in the shadow
cabinet were Junior spokesman back then
people like Peter Kyle where treating
Etc what do you think of K's own Journey
over the past few years you see a lot of
those kind of soft left people around
him have now sort of been phased out and
it's much more focus on as Katie says
competence as well as
loyalty look I
think k k had an amazing journey if you
think about it uh he he understood you
had he had to run to the left to win the
party leadership because the labor party
could have died if it made their own
choice for leader so he saved the labor
party by standing running and winning he
then was elected in the middle of a
pandemic so there's no chance you know
we all say in politics you only get one
chance to make a first impression um
Kier had no chance to get out around the
country people could people are only now
getting a sense of who he's like what
his character is like and I think he
then you know you then get hit not just
the pandemic and the economic
consequence but the war in Ukraine and
the inflation and cost of living the
massive change in circumstan over the
last couple of years um have changed the
political terrain and I think in that he
he's kind of found himself he's I've
always thought of Kier as being a left
wing version of John Smith uh Johns from
the right departy La party from the gmbb
had very traditional uh right-wing
politics for the party um but had
stolidity had respectability had trust
baked into as a like the bank manager
impression I think K's got the same
thing he's from the left of the party
but he's got that came reassuring I'm a
lawyer I'm not just a lawyer I'm a
prosecutor I put bad people away um I B
police services but when the police do
it wrong I can reorganize them change
their culture change their structure
that kind of the the culet you know you
know the the a man with a plan that's
what that's what K comes across us and I
think he's found his plan he he's had a
rocky road he know if the battle spend B
elction got a different way um there may
well have been a fullon uh a full-blown
leadership challenge but where he is now
he's in he's in the strongest position
he's ever been his opposition leader the
only time we be struggling this is on
the first day after general election if
the laboral party wins then he'll have a
full a full full power to put people at
the place he wants them to be so so I
think the journey has been interesting
he's adjusted to an incredible series of
crises in such a short period of time
and he's taken the labor party to a
steady 20 24 Point leading the polls as
Tony Blair said you know when he when
Tony was leader he he took over after
Jon Smith's hard work after Neil kinn's
hard work and he said to he said to K
and when you took over you had well you
had no like the opposite of help the
opposite of work to build on uh and so
it's one it's one of the most
Transformations uh in British politics
having done um in in just four years
what it took labor nearly four terms to
do last time R and John you're a
longtime labor Watcher we've discussed a
lot of the big names here today people
well known in kind of Westminster
circles we're led to believe that K St
will be reshuffling some of the more
Junior posts this afternoon maybe or
tomorrow um just wondered any names you
think we should keep an eye out for uh
coming up likely to be put on the first
rungs or maybe the second rung of the
Shadow ministerial ladder
but the per the person who I'd most like
to see in the shadow cabinet is is Ali
McGovern Alison McGovern who I think uh
is the is the next one uh on the rank to
come in come into politics I think you I
think you have to look at who's doing an
effective job at Prosecuting a case
that's important to labor so Matt piku
um I hope he stays in housing he's an
expert in housing he's behind the scenes
guy he's respected by the building
industry that's one of the things you
need to do is actually not move the move
the Junior around and one thing I will
say about reshuffles is in opposition
there's only one game in town that's
Shadow Cabinet member in government the
minister of State the second in command
is one of the most influential people in
in in in government in politics you take
the legislation through you you you help
sort out the department uh you're you're
you know careers are made by being a
really good minister of state and it's
it's it's those I'd like to see I'd like
to see Howen hay is kept in her post uh
in in education and I think J if I'd had
one one tip to move to move up to Shadow
uh Chief secretary I'd love to see Jes
Murray and more of Jes Mar I think he's
a real a real talent and he's done
really really well uh in that but
there's actually um an incredible breath
of uh of tell I could just simply talk
about women women in the in the Jor RS
who really really good like C hotra
there's a number of people who I think
when you see the full teams when they
are a government when they have to to do
press forces do questions be in the
house you'll see more of the range that
we've got at the moment the shadow
cabinet is a very narrow door however in
infl is to to make a political cabinet
as well he's still a small proportion of
the people who coming through and
finally uh Katie we couldn't do this
discussion without talking about Jillian
Keegan and the education secretary's
comments today in subsequent retraction
for suggestions perhaps about her work
ethic yeah she's had a day um ultimately
the the bubbly of men and the questions
about what's going to happen lot these
school buildings are still dominating
the return of Parliament and I think
it's just um a bit of a nightmare for
Richi cak and his party as it speaks to
all these things you know just you know
lots of blame game about why it wasn't
done sooner and so fast you have R
saying you know this this is not his
fault and people say it's down to his
spending decisions um but really the
focus now is the fact that jenan Keegan
was caught on the hot mic and you know
saying you know why why don't with some
swear words thrown in you know why don't
you know people ask no me done good
things we're the only people to get off
you know enter a word uh you know to to
do something about this and she's since
gone out and given enough media
appearance to clear up the comments and
apologize for the language but it's end
of her almost saying you know the
interview saying well you did seem very
annoyed why and eventually coming back
on the journalist which I'm think will
divide opinion yet again to put it
mildly um can say the big Le the big
lesson in politics is I say to
politicians when you saying uh on the
media to the voters you've got no you
you really don't understand how hard it
is to be in government and the voots
listen to it and they go you know what
we've got an idea about what to do with
ministers who think it's too hard to be
in government how about some time on the
opposition benches and I think that's
the the problem is the frustrated tone
rishy had it this morning prob r s had
it this morning Julian K had this
morning after in her non-apology apology
um I just think you if they feel tired
and Scratchy and not willing to take the
responsibility and therefore take the
opportunity of leading on this they
could fix this they could be out ahead
of the story instead we're talking about
process Loy K's being in quickly and
slickly in and out of a reshuffle and we
come back to the travails of of of the
cabinet yeah I think the only criticism
you're hearing today of K St about this
reshuffle is everyone saying it's very
efficient um I don't think that there's
too many moves that very divisive you do
have a couple of Labor MPS saying you
know h a DA when things are going so
badly for the Tories should we really be
doing the reshuffle or should we not let
them own it I think jilli and Keegan's
comments might mean the uh Tories still
get plenty of press coverage when it
comes to who wins in the colum inches
tomorrow we look forward to reading
those in the papers thank you Katie
thank you John and thank you for
watching spectator
[Music]
TV